What if humanity grew to be so technologically advanced that we were able to
leave our solar system and spread across interstellar space?
What'd we hop from one exoplanet to another,
colonizing everything in our way?
How could we make traveling across the universe possible and what would our
space civilization look like?
This is what if and here's what would happen if humanity became an interstellar
society.
No human has ever been outside of our solar system and only a few of us have
actually left the earth.
Even those who blasted out of here in a rocket,
it didn't go too far.
There are billions upon billions of planets out there,
but there's so far away.
It would take us a very long time to reach them.
If we jumped into the fastest spacecraft ever built,
it would take us over 70,000 years to get to our neighboring star system,
Alpha Centaury.
Even if we could accelerate a spaceship to 99% the speed of light over 26,000
years would pass until we arrived at the center of our own galaxy and another 2
million years until we set foot in the nearest neighbor,
the Andromeda galaxy.
How could we go about expanding our civilization into space?
If for so terribly slow
to become an inter galactic civilization,
we'd need to break the speed limit of the universe,
but for all we know,
traveling at lightspeed is physically impossible.
Nevermind outperforming it.
The Universe is enormous,
possibly infinite,
and our lifespans are two miserably short to cover those kinds of distances,
even at near Lightspeed's,
but let your curiosity takeover and imagine we were a civilization that could
approach lightspeed and travel amongst stars.
We'd start with Alpha Centaury,
our neighboring star system.
Who knows,
maybe the exoplanet orbiting this three star system would turn out to be
habitable.
Then we'd push ourselves out further to discover the billions of other worlds.
Not all of them would be suitable for us to settle in.
In astronomy.
A habitable world is a planet that has just the right distance from its sunlike
star to be able to sustain liquid water,
but the reality is humans require so much more than that atmosphere,
gravity,
temperature,
they're all important.
It's unlikely that we'd find another planet just like earth,
but we could build sustaining earthlike biomes on our giant space ships where
humans could live for generations
or we could tear a form,
some rocky exoplanets.
First we'd harvest water from a few ice comments.
Then we'd alter the planet's atmospheres to resemble Earth's anything to be able
to breathe in fresh air again.
Even though space would be so accessible,
people wouldn't travel the universe much.
Once the new colonies were established,
even at the speed of light,
it would take generations to make a trip to the other side of the universe.
Spaces just too vast.
Remember in this new world,
you'd get to travel amongst stars.
Only a few were a part of a ship's crew,
a colonist or a space minor.
We'd send robots to perform our intergalactic chores.
Robots don't eat,
sleep,
or go to the bathroom.
They can withstand high levels of radiation and extreme temperatures,
all the things that would kill a human being.
But if space travel is something you crave,
considered pursuing a career as a postal carrier because the most reliable way
to communicate might be through the mail.
Surprised.
Well,
our satellites rely on radio waves to transmit information.
Even though these waves traveled just as fast as light,
they lose their strength over long distances.
It's like being too far away from your Wifi router.
If humanity did become an interstellar society,
we humans would end up spread out across hundreds of light years of space.
At least we'd give Earth a break and allow it to recover from our mistreatment.
Maybe we don't have to go so far.
Maybe we could create a new society on artificial planets that we built around
the sun,
but that's a story for another.
What if.